A thermometer in a science lab
displays the temperature in
both Celsius and Fahrenheit.
If the mercury in the
thermometer rises to 56
degrees Fahrenheit, what is
the corresponding Celsius
temperature?
So right from the get go,
there's a formula that if you
get have the Celsius
temperature, it'll give you
the Fahrenheit, if you have the
Fahrenheit, it'll give you
the Celsius.
Now I have a bad memory,
so I always have to
pseudo-derive it.
And maybe in future videos,
we'll totally derive it.
Once we get a little bit more
algebra, if you just know the
boiling and freezing points in
both scales, you should be
able to figure out the
relationship between the two.
Now the way I always remember
it is that there's a
relationship of 5/9 or
9/5 between the two.
And then you have to
add or subtract 32.
And the way I think about it is,
the Fahrenheit number is
always going to be larger.
So if you start with-- or at
least while we are in our
normal, everyday living scales
when water is in its liquid
form and all that.
So if you start with a Celsius,
I say, oh I have to
make it bigger.
So I have to say, OK, I'm going
to multiply that by 9/5.
That will make it bigger.
And then I'm going
to add 32 to it.
And the reason why I know to add
32 is because when Celsius
is 0, 0 times 9/5 is still 0.
And we know when Celsius is 0,
Fahrenheit is going to be 32.
So I know I have to
add 32 to it.
So, at least my gut is telling
me, that the formula is 9/5
times the Celsius degrees,
plus 32.
And you can verify that this
works for the boiling point.
This definitely works for
the freezing point.
When Celsius is 0, this is going
to be 0, you add 32,
that's going to be Fahrenheit.
When Celsius is 100, 9/5 times
100 is 180, plus 32 is 212.
So this works.
They've given us the Fahrenheit
temperature, and we
need to get the Celsius
temperature.
Now I could just put the 56 in
here, and solve for C, and
that will completely work.
Or I could solve for C using
this, so I have the equation
for Celsius in terms
of Fahrenheit.
Either way.
So let's do it the
second way, so we
have the second equation.
So if we subtract 32 from both
sides of this equation, we get
Fahrenheit minus 32 is equal
to 9/5 times Celsius.
Now to solve for Celsius, we
can multiply both sides of
this equation times 5/9.
And so we will get 9 cancels
with 9, 5 cancels with 5.
That was the whole point behind
multiplying by the
reciprocal.
Remember, this 5/9 is going to
be times this whole left side.
We're left with Celsius.
Celsius is equal to 5/9 times
Fahrenheit, minus 32.
So we just rearranged this
equation up here to get this
equation down here.
I didn't derive the equation in
this video, I just kind of
pseudo-remembered it, and made
sure I got the equation right.
But you can derive it if
you just remember, it's
essentially, if you know
how to find the
equation of a line.
You say, well, when Celsius-- if
you use the x-coordinate as
Celsius-- when Celsius is
0, Fahrenheit is 32.
And when Celsius is 100,
Fahrenheit is 212, and find
the equation of the line between
these two points.
Don't worry about it if
you don't know that.
All you need to know for this
problem is this right here.
But if you know how to solve the
equation for the line, you
would come up with this answer
right here, and you wouldn't
have to memorize it.
Now that we've actually gotten
this far, let's just put in 56
degrees for the Fahrenheit
temperature, and figure out
what the Celsius
temperature is.
So if we put 56 in there, we're
going to have 5/9 times
56 minus 32 is equal to the
Celsius temperature.
So 56 minus 32-- let me
continue it up here.
56 minus 30 is 26,
minus 2 is 24.
So this is going to be 24.
So it's going to be
5/9 times 24.
This right here is 24.
5/9 times 24 is going
to be equal to C.
And let's see if we can
simplify this at all.
So this is the same thing
as 5 times 24 over 9.
24 is divisible by 3.
You divide it by 3, you get 8.
9 divided by 3 is 3.
So 5 times 8 is equal to 40/3
Celsius, degrees Celsius.
Now if we wanted to write this
as a mixed number, 3 goes into
40 thirteen times.
And you have a remainder of 1.
So it's 13 and 1/3.
Now we could even check that.
3 times 13 is 39,
plus 1 is 40.
And if this wasn't obvious to
you, you could actually just
take 3 into 40.
3 goes into 4 one time.
1 times 3 is 3.
Subtract.
You get 1.
Bring down that 0.
3 goes into 10 three times.
3 times 3 is 9.
You subtract.
You get a remainder of 1.
So it's 3 and 1/3.
So this is 13 and 1/3
degrees Celsius.
So if it's 56 degrees outside in
Fahrenheit, it's 13 and 1/3
degrees in Celsius.